[Music]
after 20 seasons of tv
and eight actually good seasons of tv
the worldwide phenomenon that launched a
thousand memes
finally comes to the big screen at least
a decade after anyone over the age of 12
stopped giving a crap
it's like if they put out a family guy
movie now
go the simpsons movie
remember the simpsons they're back in
movie form
for a film that you'd swear was just a
long episode of the show
if it weren't for some weird digital
animation shots and a big dose of
edginess that no one asked for
featuring lynches boobs
and bart stick good luck sneaking all
that under disney plus
i'm the mascot of an evil corporation
that's awkward meet the simpsons a
perfect representation of how harvard
nerds envision a middle-class family
lisa is an inconvenient truther who can
resist an environmentalist or a guy with
an accent
much less both is your name as pretty as
your face
[Music]
marge is so fed up with being right she
tapes a divorce message over her wedding
video
i'm leaving with the kids to help
springfield
and we're never coming back it's funny
because it's true
barn is acting out because he's missing
a strong authority figure
which might be why he turned to
scientology for answers hey what's
happening man this is bart simpson
just kidding don't hang up this is nancy
cartwright i'm now auditing
on new ot7 and by this point in
simpson's history homer has evolved from
a flawed but caring father into an
irredeemable jerk ass crossed with wiley
coyote
[Music]
okay enough looney tunes stuff get back
to the child abuse i'll
teach you to laugh at something that's
funny laugh along with all the hilarious
side characters you know and love
until a cheap hank scorpio knockoff
traps them all under a dome
leaving us with plenty of time for the
simpsons to poke fun at alaska
okay while the residents of springfield
descend into a mad max style apocalypse
off-camera i am now the emperor of
springfield
oh i want to see the emperor moe movie
maybe that's where spider-pig went for
the second half
oh no they ate him didn't they
experience the thrill of watching all
the best simpsons writers returning
to reuse plot lines from episodes they
made decades ago
featuring the simpsons kids being raised
by the flanders multi-eyed creatures
born of illegal water pollution
and native american vision quest
prompted by spicy food
boy please hey simpsons movie simpsons
did it
but if the franchise is known for
anything these days it's predicting the
future
as you know we've inherited quite a
budget crunch from president trump
and this film is no exception completely
nailing the plot of stephen king's next
book
tom hanks becoming more credible than
the us government the u.s government has
lost its credibility so it's borrowing
some of mine and the mandalorian
i have spoken so gather around for a
good but not great simpsons experience
which is still light years ahead of most
of the other comedies you could be
watching on disney plus
pelvic trust try this and while it's
become our national pastime to complain
about the show's declining quality
we'd all watch a sequel to this in a
heartbeat
see you in 2035 movie
starring american king of the family guy
[Music]
small fry gal gore simpson
she's mute she's cute she scoots through
shoots
the prophet abraham plucky charms
spider pig will return in spider-man 3.
jank scorpio and fandom
i've spent my entire life doing nothing
but collecting comic books
and now there's only time to say
life well spent infinite seasons and a
movie
well during the avalanche scene homer is
carrying four logs and three logs then
four logs again i mean
what are we supposed to believe is some
sort of magical log or something
boy i really hope somebody got fired for
that blunder are you a wizard of
nintendo power
do you think you were born to hyrule the
mushroom kingdom come prove it and win
real money by competing in the fandom 5
nintendo trivia show
click the box or the link in the
description to sign up
dear homer i owe you one emergency donut
signed homer
we live in a society ohana means
family family means nobody gets left
behind
or forgotten i wanna be
the very best like no one ever was